this is a production of Cornell
University
well thank you that's a really exciting
talks one of the things that I noticed
is sort of a theme through all the talks
was the environmental sustainability
that's coming along with this food
revolution so in addition to having
fresh nutritious locally sourced foods
it's also a more environmentally
sustainable system in many cases Michael
can you talk a little bit more about the
food lack of food waste and how that's
helping environment yeah so in terms of
a lot of the energy we put into a farm
if you think about of what we our
presence on the planet means in terms of
the the water we use where we get
fertility for the crops to grow and
handle the cultivation all the energy
that goes into just kind of getting the
crop ready in the field one of the big
things we can do is to look at you know
how to use more of that and so there's a
work like I'm doing to be able to see
how we can get more of that to be edible
there's also the complementary work and
a lot I do it with Chris on trying to
look at how you can avoid some of the
diseases and testin might go in and
cause the great loss of that and the
flood moves in some diseases move in how
can you make plans more resilient and
what might happen through this season
and so as we're working on kind of
combining all those and then if we're
the links to the things that Thomas was
sharing about how you can look at some
of the supply chains and get more of
that crop kind of fitting into what
people are looking to buy in addition to
what I'm doing to try to encourage and
expand what is working really well in a
given environment and can be translated
to a dinner table
Thanks and yeah we'll get your questions
in just one second I wanted to bring up
one more point both Thomas
well actually Thomas Courtney and
Carman all brought up the point that
Cornell and cows does have a campus in
Geneva New York there's about 300 people
there working there now
and we're celebrating the Geneva Campus
is celebrating its one hundred and
thirty fifth anniversary this year and
and carmen i know you said that the high
pressure processing machine was there in
Geneva I'm interested to know I know you
said that the Teflon coating that could
be used to prevent bacteria from
sticking was increasing environmental
sustainability because you might not use
other other chemicals it's in any way
that the HPP machine increased
environmental sustainability in fact
many of these non-thermal we call the
non thermal technologies are not relying
on heat so because you don't have to put
so much thermal energy into the
processing and you don't have to cool
after that there are some savings
depending on the product depending on
how energy intensive the product is in
the end so both high pressure but also
other technologies like pulsed electric
field and other things that we are going
to use have been demonstrating certain
cases to reduce the use of energy
additionally with high pressure you
treat the product in package already so
it removes the need for repackaging
after that and also it increases shelf
life because you have treated the
products its terminal treatment you
don't have any post process
contamination so that could extend the
shelf life and also has the energy
benefit and just last comment on the
Teflon that was kind of a catchy phrase
from the media our surface actually is
not Teflon is like Teflon for bacteria
they called it you leave it to the media
to call it catch away but it's really
just metallic surface it's a metal oxide
let's cool so other questions from the
audience
it's a two-part question what is your
definition of local and does the
definition of local eventually hurt them
marketing-wise because they can only be
local common as a local is a term that's
not legally defined of course so it
means whatever the consumer needs it to
mean and there are many attributes of
local many reasons people want to buy
local and it depends which one is most
important depends on the store so one of
the attributes of local is that it's
fresher so if you're interested in the
freshness of your produce buying it so
that it traveled less is an important
criterion there but it can also be that
you want to feel a connectedness to the
community if you live in a small town
you want to know that this person went
to school with your mother grew the
thing that is an important aspect of
local in some situations less so in big
cities but there's also the regional
connectedness the regional identity this
comes from my place and that's really
very important to people and how far my
place extends depends on the type of
community you have and you end up with
some oddity so in New York City in the
restaurant foodservice trade they use
the pride of New York label as their
indicator of local so if it comes from
Buffalo it's local but if it comes from
northern New Jersey it's not so that's a
cultural definition of local so those
the exact definition depends on what the
quality of localness is that somebody is
after and there are many different
legitimate ones they have to be
addressed and do you think that impacts
markets so sort of the fog oh it impacts
markets tremendously you see in the here
in the supermarkets where we are out in
the country they'll put pictures of the
farmer in which little town the farm is
in to develop that connected
because we take the fresh for granted in
the summertime anyway about what impact
climate change may have on your plant
breeding focus as it relates to crop
adaptation and pest resistance or
managing pests so we're seeing in the in
the berry world not only climate change
changing the climate pattern so
California has just went through a large
drought period of course now that's been
broken last summer here didn't rain also
for weeks and weeks and this year hasn't
stopped raining so it's certainly what
we see in the pest side of things the
pressure changes a lot if you add into
that the the reduction in use of what we
call fumigants and these are used in a
lot of the berry production to to reduce
the pests in the soil before they plant
many of these chemicals are harmful to
the environment and so they're phasing
them out in many places and now so we
have the berry growers and very breeders
have had to concentrate more resources
toward making sure the plant can
withstand diseases that they used to
just avoid through their production
practices so having better route
tolerance to heavier soils to pathogens
to wet and dry climate and then being
able to breed varieties that will grow
in more modern production systems such
as the protected agriculture of the
tunnels because the things that grow
well in the field don't necessarily grow
well under those conditions and so
combining both production practices with
some of the environmental problems has
has really changed my focus on how we
deal with it I just add a little bit to
that now throughout the president plant
breeding we're always finding the the
best of the best and tightening of
with so once once in a great attributes
and another plant that has something's a
compliment that they'll add to that when
they're cross together so for me I'm
increasingly looking to more global
sources for plants that might not be I
might not be crossing to plants that are
that's exactly the same you might
confuse them if you see them as being
the same but looking at some of the more
kind of wilder versions or the versions
of a cucumber that a different culture
would use in India Thailand where
they're having many of these climate
conditions we're bracing ourselves for
and making those making that exchange
between cultures at the seed level in
our food that's how I'm kind of bringing
the resilience I probably have the
easiest one on that one because we're
breeding for tolerance to warmer nights
and that is clearly one of the trends
that we're seeing so having that trait
developed in this particular crop that's
going to help continue to have
production in the areas where it's
continuing we're also of course looking
at ways to raise the crop that have
lower impacts on climate change that are
better better storage of carbon that's
that's a piece of the production also so
we're looking at both ends
well certainly the locally-sourced
movement has in the east it's been very
very strong and I think in the Pacific
Northwest it's also been very very
strong part of that availability because
they can grow a lot of horticultural
crops and so then that people start to
think well why are we getting it from so
far away
obviously in December berries are not
really sore scible from New York for the
most part in January February so that
certainly is part of it part of its the
environmental part of it
part of it is if people think well what
doesn't make sense to grow things and
ship it in a truck all the way across
the country
unfortunately the economics and the
carbon footprint doesn't always match
that because there are yield differences
in different places and strawberries in
California yield about three times as
much per acre as they do in New York and
so that balance for the carbon footprint
may not be as advantageous because it's
not just about shipping so it's a
combination of the shipping part of it
and the quality part of it that we're
trying to combine others may come in
yeah microphone I have I have a question
and a comment I've been a faithful eater
broccoli for numerous years and then I
found a chart by the center of Disease
Control that said watercress was a
hundred percent nutrient dense and
broccoli 38 so I was wondering are you
doing any work with watercraft
as being higher nutrition I mean I
didn't realize that been eating broccoli
forever yeah I think part of it is that
a lot of the nutrients are in the green
part of the plants and with broccoli the
center of the stem doesn't have as much
of some of the vitamins that they're
counting in their nutrient density
calculation but one of the trade-offs of
course is that it's easier to eat a lot
you can easily eat three times as much
broccoli as watercress in most
situations so so in terms of the total
nutrient impact they end up being
similar the crucifer in general are
pretty good I wanted to make a comment I
received my nutrition degree from here
40 years ago and develop the Lean
Cuisine products for Stouffer's the
first 10 but I retired end of December
2015 and went to India on a medical
missions trip
the doctors dentists and nurses and one
of the areas were going up the stairs to
Center and my hug someone from my team
said look out the window and I saw all
this rubble from the construction
breaking down demolishes and they said
the children lives there there's no
bathroom nothing food water and they
come every day and they get one hot meal
make a shower in the area that I was
working at and I was sad and then I said
to myself I'll just
happy for them right now and do whatever
I can right now
and came home this is a year ago and
there was an email 3.5 million dollars
given to malnourished children in India
given to the AG and the nutrition human
that by Bill Gates so it is just so
exciting and the agricultural school is
going to find ways of growing more on
things for the people and then our
nutrition group is going to provide
better food for them but it was just so
wonderful so happy so I went back to
India again this year and Beck thinks
because we go next year but it's fun
thank you very much for sharing that
story actually it's a real pleasure of
ours to interact with folks at Cal's
international programs many of the folks
across scales are not only focused on
you know communities here in in New York
but across the US and around the world
so thank you for sharing that
I don't think there's a based on what I
saw in the NA s report there's no
evidence at all for for the fact that
it's genetically modified being the
causal agents of that it's of course
it's some of those public health trends
are remain rather mysterious we didn't
have the Apple iPhone either so I mean
there's a lot of there's a lot of things
that have changed in our society besides
our food source and and a lot of that
hat is are we become more sedentary
which is not good for your health we've
changed our eating habits so it's really
hard to pinpoint specific things what we
have seen in the last 10 years is
increased consumption of produce and the
government has been trying to get people
to eat more produce because we feel good
for you
so making cause-and-effect connections
is very very challenging in those kinds
of situations when you have population
size that we do that's also changed and
that's changing rapidly worldwide as
well I don't think you'll find that the
percentages of people with Crohn's
disease for instance has gone up but
there's more people and more people are
much more aware of it and so we hear a
lot more about it too and so I think
that as a big part as well our news
cycle has changed tremendously to a you
know that if it bleeds it leads has
changed into all aspects of the news
that we get and so it's a little
challenging for us that scientists we
see the scientific evidence has not
backed up some of the news that is in
the cycle
yeah you know they said so then it's
there's you know it's probably a it's a
an active and necessary area of inquiry
into kind of what are the things that
sensitize us or kind of increase the
likelihood that someone will develop
these things and kind of figure out what
are what are those how can we avoid them
how can we minimize them and think about
just all the complexity Courtney said
about some of the lifestyle things
there's a lot of news we've looked about
the chemicals we interact with in our
daily live and so on food
there's also chemicals that we're
looking at to see which ones are we
interacting with and which ones might be
triggers or not and for different people
which and we're all different we'll
respond to things differently also but
you know looking at a vast spectrum of a
very complicated system and trying to
tease out of course how can we change
the things that might be triggers of
such things to help you know in all the
ways the food impacts us and their
environment impact yes and in addition
to finding out causes we're also working
on solutions we have folks across the
college and in human ecology as well
nutritionists looking at how can we help
the folks that have been diagnosed with
these issues we have folks breeding
specifically for people that have gluten
issues so how can we breed crops that
can then be used by our food science
colleagues to produce gluten-free foods
so we absolutely are recognizing the
issues that exist and working towards
scientific solutions for the problem
other questions so I have oh is there
one more I have flash questions for that
for the panel to finish us up today I'd
like to ask the question about food
safety at farmer's markets especially if
you're buying foods that you're not
going to cook or heat treat do you how
does the panel feel about the food
safety on a farmers market versus in a
supermarket
well it turns out my wife is the
national leader in developing food
safety programs for farmers and that
extends from the small plane farmers
Amish Mennonite all the way to the
multinational corporation it is
certainly a concern and it is Cornell
its leading the way in in developing
programs for farmers to actually have a
plan on how to avoid contaminating their
produce certainly it's in the news when
there's an outbreak in spinach or melons
or strawberries or whatever it hits the
news cycle instantaneously and it scares
people on it and it's what's reason you
don't want to find out that you fed your
child something that's going to make
them sick so part of that is federal
government has actually come out with a
new new law they call it FISMA Food
Safety Modernization Act most of you
probably don't know about it and don't
have to know about it but Cornell is
part of that process of getting rules
and helping farmers put together plans
so that they can be as safe as possible
there is no such thing as no risk on a
farm it just you can't eliminate it
completely because food is grown in the
ground but farmers are very aware of
this no farmer wants to make their
customer sick it will destroy them and
so they are they're a lot more careful
than they were 10 years ago and they
will be continued to implement a lot of
these plans I think for most of the
local stuff especially the thing that
you can take some comfort in as most of
these farmers are eating their produce
before they're selling it to you because
they're feeding their own families with
it as well it's certainly a concern
though so it's much less awkward for me
to say than Kourtney but Cornell
takes an amazing sense of pride in our
leadership in good agricultural
practices and food safety in addition to
Kourtney's wife
Betsie been the entire department of
food science has just really led I think
the state the country in the world and
good agricultural practices and safe
food in fact the state of New York is
really leading the world our our state
partners have funded much of the work
and research as well so if it's a really
revolutionary area for corner for
Cornell Inc and calzone so my flash
questions Oklahoma okay I was just
wondering the timeframe in terms of the
enactment of that Modernization Act and
how that's reaching us in the
marketplace we can our food safety has
dropped so the question about the Food
Safety Modernization Act that is being
implemented as we speak so they have
been training for the last six seven
months now around the country they've
been doing a lot of train the trainers
so in that process you train other
people who can then go out and train
even more people and so that process is
ongoing as we speak and my wife Betsy
has been traveling a lot in the last six
months all over the country they've
covered about 30 of the states now most
of those you'll notice around the edge
the center part of the country and the
Upper West doesn't grow a whole lot of
produce but they will get to all of the
states by the end of this year with
trainings and so big the rules are going
coming into place I think some of them
are for the larger farms by the end of
this year and then all the whole process
by the end of next year it's been a
multi-year rollout of those regulations
it's coming from other countries so
there is an international there is an
international section of this and
international farms have to meet the
same standards and so they are training
people outside the country as well who
import food into the United States
because they will have to follow the
same and they really are they monitored
monitoring is always a
what you'll find is that you know we get
a lot of produce from Mexico and people
worry about oh we're getting this
produce from Mexico what do they do in
Mexico that we don't know allow turns
out most of the company's growing in
Mexico are companies that are growing in
California as well and so they have an
integrated food safety plan throughout
the company and so they do the exact
same the exact same thing in Mexico as
they do in in California or Arizona or
somewhere else because they're putting
produce into the same stream so when
Driscoll sells strawberries whether they
come from California or Florida or
Mexico they want to have the same
standards everywhere because they can't
afford not to because they have worked
really hard and spent a lot of money to
get their name to be recognized as
something of quality and I think you'll
see the same with companies like dole
and and and some of these big produce
companies they they are very very
careful about their reputation so so as
a consumer what are the top things I
should be looking for thinking about
okay the top things I mean anybody has
nothing I think eating enough produce is
probably more important than worrying
about where the produce comes from I
think most of us don't eat enough
produce so I've been told that I need to
wrap up my one of my last lightening
questions as scientists when we give
talks the last thing we always do is
acknowledge the folks who have funded
our work so I was going to ask each of
them but I won't because I know it will
take too long I'm going to give a
running list of what I know has been
funded and throughout cows were funded
by the growers of the state of New York
many many different grower groups we're
funded by industry we have many industry
partners that are willing to help fund
the work because it's important to what
happens to them we're funded by the
United States Department of Agriculture
federal funding sources the National
Science Foundation the National
Institutes of Health the state of New
York provides a significant amount of
funding
and the College of Agriculture and life
sciences and with that I'd like to thank
our panel members again this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu